but Comstock how you doing good welcome
to the industrialist dilemma thank you
um and and you know it's what's
interesting is as we've been thinking
about this and as we were working with
Max and talking max over the past couple
of years about the industrialist dilemma
and this whole kind of concept an issue
in general GE has always sort of come
back as like the canonical example of a
company that is responding to a whole
bunch of challenges of moving from an
industrial business to one that is a
digitally enabled industrial business or
maybe even a digital first or
digital-only business over time so so
there's a lot the way you I think we
want to get through so maybe just to
kick things off you're the vice-chair of
GE maybe you could first just describe
you know what
what is your purview what is your job
light and what is the state of GE today
well I'll start with the latter the
state of G is really strong in a tough
market
I mean you tough world of markets I
guess I should say kind of slow to no
growth in many of the markets we do
business but you still have to grow and
that's a big part of my job is to ramp
up the growth engines of GE you have to
have new growth it has to come from new
places businesses can't stop growing and
that's my mandate is to help the company
figure out how to grow and how to
continue to find new ways to grow and
what um so GE we just talked about the
heritage of GE and the sort of varied
businesses that you guys are in and
maybe just like when did it hit the
organization that this whole digital
thing was going to transform GE and how
has it been you know where are you in
the journey and how has it begun to kind
of transform the business yeah I think
it's been sort of you know in the
background for probably the past decade
and I spend a lot of time in the media
world and I think you start when you're
in GE because certainly even a decade
ago we had many more businesses and in
many more industries than we are now one
of the things that's happened over the
past 10 years we've been very had to
focus our portfolio but if you look at
sort of the early indicators you'd have
to look at media where you started to
see digitization I spin it was immersed
for several years in the middle of all
that you start to see business models
changing you start to see disruption
happening then you pick your head up and
you
see hey it's starting to happen in
healthcare the digitization of the
consumer of the patient experience in a
few years later you start to see little
glimmers of it happening in the energy
space and so you know you start to
connect some dots there and I'd say for
us probably about maybe 2008 we started
to really pick her head up and really by
you know 2011 or so we said this is
serious and we were doing some
experiments and testing and so for the
past four to five years it's been
redefining the future of the company and
you have a way that that you can kind of
describe how that has redefined the
company universally across because
obviously so many different businesses
but like what is the what is the center
of all of that well first we had to say
what does digitization mean to the
company and we we saw the opportunity we
had to kind of name it to claim it we
said we see the industrial internet it's
there's been a great consumer internet
we've all experienced but what you
haven't yet seen is the Internet of
Industry and so again is we were seeing
these things connected so we said okay
we're gonna name it and claim it even
though it doesn't exist and we don't
know how to get there
industrial Internet what does that mean
I have to be honest from Silicon Valley
we thought you guys were on crack yeah I
know but remember I don't know if you
read that first big event we had were
you at the first big event we had this
was it was not far from here we had a
big event and Jeff Immelt on the stage
and Marc Andreessen and behind him Jeff
we we flew in this huge shell of a
turbine of a jet engine and Jeff looked
at Marc and he said you know Marc's
mixing software eats the world and Jeff
looks back and he goes eat this market
so that was
the early stages of us trying to define
what it meant and honestly at that stage
we thought it was either/or with
software versus hardware and so we we we
embedded it first in our research center
because that was really what we were
doing the technical R&D can we get the
kind of look at what do we need to do
what's the technology that is going to
empower and enable this digital world
and then pretty soon thereafter we had
to start empowering sales and marketing
teams and getting all the businesses on
board but that's really been the journey
of the past and so it answer your
question finally I'm sorry but I think
so now we're we know what our destiny is
for certainly the next decade or more
we're a digital industrial company and
you I think for us it really is being at
that intersection of the digital and the
physical world and I don't think I think
they're both important and it's soon
though you guys took a remarkably
iterative process to kind of get there
because just to kind of continue what
I'm saying like first it looked kind of
crazy like what are you guys talking
about industrial internet like just
sounds like the Internet yeah but coming
from GE or some things that will be just
bigger more expensive so it it kind of
started you can connect the dots of like
what the internet could do to the
various products you guys had did you
know what kind of sort of change that
would drive within the business at first
or did you actually like did it kind of
come together in slow pieces it's
definitely I think the one thing you
know as well as anybody
it's always an iterative I think
generally in companies there's always an
iterative process and it drives people
crazy because they expect it to be done
so I think first we had to just
understand do we have the right
technology the sensors and controls how
do we what are the applications what's
the opportunity so one of the first
things we did really was just if that
name it claim it here's the market we
started to say hey we think this is
going to unlock a whole new wave of
productivity and industry and we've
decided hey even if we can unlock 1% of
productivity in the healthcare industry
that's six hundred million dollars in
the rail business that's you know
multiple hundreds of millions you start
to add up it's like trillions of dollars
worth of productivity in the industries
we serve so hey there's a market there's
mark there are markets there what are
the applications and so in the early
days it was a lot of goofy applications
to be honest
one off let's just see if we can do it
then over time you start to say hey an
application in rail actually we're gonna
track where our locomotives are that
same application works in a hospital
where you want to track where your thing
where the nurse wants to find where all
the healthcare pieces of equipment are
so you start to see that this disparate
pieces actually fit together more
horizontally than you think and but you
guys could have sort of delivered that
as just okay now G Eve's products are
smarter they're more intelligent but it
seemed like there was an overall
business model shift that came along
with the industrial internet what was
that what was that shift had and and
were you guys in that journey right now
well to one of the points that was
raised earlier there were two shifts the
technology the hardware engineers are
not good at software so you had to
convince them that this was a different
kind of engineering capability that had
to be embedded we actually had a lot of
software capability in various pieces we
now had to aggregate them hire more and
then we were totally lost on the
commercial side what are we selling what
are we selling an app are we selling a
service we had to get to the point and
someone mentioned it here earlier that
we're selling an outcome again if you're
driving productivity what does it mean
I'm going to give you no unplanned
downtime if you're running a power plant
and you don't expect that gas turbine to
go down that's millions and millions of
dollars a day so again you started to
say what is it and you could see that
across the whole company so we had to
import new software technology and new
sales and marketing technology and is
that something that's sort of fully
standardized across the business or
these sort of unique relationships you
have with a bunch of your customers
where you guys get into a room and you
say okay we're gonna save you two
billion dollars give us half of that and
and then you go on your way or is that
something that's fully kind of programa
ties or productized across it's a little
of both in the beginning you have to
figure it out customer by customer
industry by industry and I'd say the
good news for us is our customers
weren't ready either so we weren't ready
and they weren't ready but we were all
ready to see the vision and have the
discussion and we had to come up with a
customer maturity model that some of our
most sophisticated customers were ready
most of them weren't ready at all they
didn't know what we were talking about
luckily we didn't either so it worked
out really well we could we could take
each other along but that's something
you always have when you're when you're
kind of making a market
you're dealing with varying degrees of
maturity of your customers the other
thing that's interesting is who is your
customer you're calling in a much higher
order that's about productivity of
operations you're suddenly becoming a
partner in operating a railroad
operating an airline your customers no
longer certainly the procurement officer
it's not your service officer
it's the CFO the CEO the CIO so suddenly
the CIOs in this really interesting
position of doing like operational
technology and information technology so
you're also having to change the role of
the people that you work with in the
customer level did you start this with
one group inside of GE or did you try to
roll it out across all the divisions
simultaneously a little of both gia is
pretty good at doing kind of centralized
centers of expertise and so we brought
in the technology and the commercial
capabilities and then everybody tried to
tap into that and it frankly didn't
scale so we had to just last year had to
come in and say it's not we don't have
enough heft everybody's all in we have
one digital Center running it like a
business and they they drive the
implementation the commercialization and
then they pivot back to the businesses
that was a huge cultural shift for us
have you had to do anything to ensure
that that business unit then that group
is not slowed down by yes they sort of
notions of the overall company yeah and
partly its co-locating we have a
Software Center out in the East Bay and
we've now got about 2,500 software
engineers and data analysts and all
kinds of as you'd imagine sophisticated
technologists but we had to say okay if
you're in healthcare you have to put
your digital team here the chief digital
officer for energy sits in San Ramon and
he has to port back to the power and
water business in France in Schenectady
you know so so that was reassuring the
center of expertise and now we're a
global company so now we're setting up
digital foundries in Shanghai in Israel
in your in France so then you have to
also figure out how do you how are you
distributed to serve global markets so
now we're at that phase but did you
have then these junctures where what the
digital team was building or the
software group at the time was building
wasn't competitive they're either on
cost or performance was something that
one of those teams could have gotten
from the outside market did you have to
sort of force them to use it anyway for
the product development process and
improving that or did you let them go in
different direction and how did you deal
with the fact that that that this thing
was so early and and how do you let it
kind of blossom well this gives you an
indication we just released predicts
which is our industrial cloud we just
opened it up for general availability
two weeks ago so you might well imagine
some of our business units were ready
before the industrial cloud was ready so
there had to be a transition plan so you
had to say that you had to say to the
rail business there are certain things
you need to move forward on because your
customers expecting it but know at some
point we're going to have to manage the
cost and the transition we had to create
cloud that is on-premise in the cloud
you had to create secure parts open
parts we had to partner with that we do
partner with Amazon Web service to get
some of that speed so you had to come up
with a real mosaic of options if you
will for the business units sometimes
they did it better over time they had to
know this centralized predicts stack is
where they're gonna be and they had to
figure out how to manage to that I think
we want to get a lot more into the pre
Dix business model on that as because
that's a pretty interesting example of
you guys kind of inventing a new
software business on top of the GE kind
of Corbett
but before do that if you move into a
model where you are selling outcomes for
your customers and you are a service
provider not just a selling a product do
you ever run into issues where now
you're competing with previous partners
or suppliers in your industry that were
stuck between you and the customer or
the ultimate product how have you guys
navigated that if they were navigating
it now and it rings in a whole-new I've
mentioned earlier that CIO who's now
super important to us and they are
making critical decisions and they're
being called on by AP IBM ge and
everybody thinks it's a IT solution when
actually we're offering an OT solution
so partly you have to kind of do
get out a little bit okay and for us it
was coming with the operational
expertise not trying to do an EE RP
implementation like we're not good at
that but we're good at what we're so you
do find that kind of conflict because
none of us really have figured out what
it means in the industrial Internet so
we had to work through that we still are
and I assume you even connected me with
many of the system integrators the
extension of the world people who had to
package all this up together or is that
I think we partner more thorough so I
think you're seeing us through a lot
more with Accenture Capgemini some of
those those kind of systems integrators
and at some point we may face that as a
as a question to ask should we be doing
that right now we're partnering but so
that that's an example of you guys
competing with sort of ostensibly
partners previous partners what about do
you ever find yourself competing with
like your actual end customer of your
technology because you're jumping a step
ahead of them in terms of delivering
that integrated solution yes and no I
mean sometimes the more sophisticated
customers that have the sophisticated IT
or ot teams that can do their own apps
sometimes you were in competition with
them but again if you're opening your if
you're opening your your platform your
cloud up to them you basically say build
it great we'd love you to build it just
build it here we don't need to build
everything for you so I think that was a
mindset shift for our company for people
are used to controlling everything to
say I don't care how you build them we
can build them if you want the sum we're
not going to touch and if you want to do
it we'd like you to do it here and how
do we incent you or help you help you
feel comfortable that this is going to
work for you how did you change the
culture internally where things had to
be deterministic had to be reliable
because of the importance of what you
built in healthcare and the like too
much more of an open standards and api's
where you don't know what's gonna happen
when somebody taps into this well I
think it's that marriage of the software
engineers and the hardware engineers
coming together we did a lot with lean
lean methodology especially Lean Startup
me a lot of things that were incubated
here at Stanford with Steve Blank and
Eric Ries we brought in Eric Ries as a
coach and I remember the first time we
brought him in sort of the thought
bubble you could see in everybody's head
was like okay smarty-pants i know you
know software what do you know about
hardware two years later people were
saying to him I know you know hardware
but what do you know about
so that idea of sort of the the agile
just get it going you know that you had
to think differently and software so
basically software had to kind of lead
those implementations and say to the
hardware guys learn from me and we had
to incent people differently we had
different metrics on in terms of speed
capital allocation throughput in terms
of how long you're waiting for a product
to be developed so we had to change our
measurement systems as well and it
you're a level then in the organization
or you does who is brokering or then
arbitrating than the two speeds and when
things need to come together versus
because you could easily slow down the
software business because the hardware
you know people get too connected to it
like do you ever have to kind of
separate things or do you want as
integrated as possible
well you want it as integrated as
possible but you also don't want to lose
the customer so you whatever you do you
want to make sure you're you're you have
to bring your customer along but you
want to move at market speed I'd say you
want to make sure you're not slowing
your customer down when they want to go
faster and so that always has to become
the determination if it becomes an
internal fight of hardware versus
software but the customers left out not
good so again Lean Startup has given us
the tools to think much faster with our
with our customers did you have again
given the diversity of the businesses is
probably hard but but was there ever
like a North Star or a company that you
guys looked up to and said hey we want
to model our future off of this type of
business or was it a like multiple
companies what what was the framework
that you're operating on when you move
from the industrial to digital I think
it was a mosaic there were a lot of
different pieces I mean you you know you
have to look at like an Apple model as a
platform what happened with iTunes and
the applications and understand sort of
network orchestration and platform
business models that that was something
you had to look at and how that's
impacted of other industries you had to
look at just a lot of different
companies that change their business
models so you know going from sort of
for us we we had had some great history
of transitioning our service model we
were looking at other people so that the
integrators you talked about the
extensors of the world how do they do it
what can we learn from them I'd say
there were a lot of different models on
any the
anything we had Tony Fadell in here the
beginning of the course has nest ever
been have you learned much from NASA's
nest learn from you guys I mean that's
another example of a sort of fully
integrated hardware software cloud IOT
he he doesn't like the word IOT or the
concept but but was there any kind of
shared understanding between your worlds
well I think great have great admiration
for what Tony was able to do quickly
I'll tell you one thing we did it didn't
work but we launched a partnership in a
series of experiments on the consumer
side to have connected home because we
felt it was a good laboratory that
eventually consumer data is going to
feed into the energy value chain and so
we partnered with the startup called
quirky and created a bunch of connected
products had our own at the time naively
nest killer which basically ended up
killing quirky so but but the reality is
that you have to have plant those seeds
to understand and learn and we hope we
hadn't done that I think we wouldn't
have learned some of the key things
we're doing now with connected
lightbulbs so quirky is a that's
actually a fun example then you brought
it up not me so basically how do you
guys deal with then taking risks and and
and how do you create an environment
that has a lot of four keys to exist
which is a you know company you guys put
a lot of money into the concept was a
fairly novel you know could have worked
could you know maybe not didn't how do
you guys deal with that I'd say first of
all I think in Jeff ml you have a CEO
and chairman there's a very market focus
CEO he said to drive growth from new
sources since since the day he got in
there and so he has this great attitude
of we have to try things i I don't think
every CEO comes to the job with that and
he's maintained that despite a lot of
people who who think maybe we shouldn't
have tried as many things but I think he
has an appetite for us trying things he
knows it's important and we've had to
just continue to evaluate our models and
one of the things I think is been very
successful for us we have a ventures
team just on Sand Hill Road here and
yeah we partner in invest in startups
but more and more we're incubating our
own businesses and so we're trying to
create those challenger brands
challenger companies within the
mothership and happy to talk about that
but I think you have to create space for
the
ideas you have to partner you can't do
everything yourself if there's one thing
we've changed our culture is that you
can't do it alone and I mean I think
about our relationship as a company I'd
say I you you can offer if I've got it
right but I think it was tough for you
to come into G because everybody's like
we can do it ourselves right we we don't
need box we can do it ourselves and and
so you have to come back and say well
really we can't do it ourselves good
actually we need air yeah but that is
that is the fallacy of companies you
think you can do it all yourself if you
look at the company five to ten years
out how do you think it changes and
looks as an organization where do you
think revenue streams come from versus
where it is today well I think you have
more revenue streams for more sources so
this is one of the lessons I feel like
I've learned dating back to my NBC days
of digital is the pie get in the digital
world the pie gets bigger the pieces get
smaller so you have to work harder for
more pieces of the pie so basically
you're layering on revenue stream
revenue stream revenue stream it makes
the finance team crazy the cost of the
cost if you're not careful it can you
know in the early stages is more
expensive until you get to entitlement
so I think that's one of the things that
we're just now getting getting our head
around but do you think that that's what
edging so the pie gets bigger the pieces
gets smaller are there the pieces like
have the same toppings or like or like
is there no like okay no I don't even
know what I remember
there's a weird birthday cake some
Carvel yeah but like is there synergy
between the pieces well I think there
has to be some synergy I would say the
only like asterisks on that rule is if
you get there early and first and you
have more you can have access to more
pieces in the platform strategy right I
mean look at the Facebook's the apples
they have more pieces because they're
counting on other people to bring them
the data and so so you you you can start
to be a toll collector in some of these
some of these models so so those are
some of the things we're trying to get
our head around and I don't know where
it's all going to end up for us but
those are the things you have to think
about real-time so when you think about
then what was the number what was the
revenue number we said 230 billion is
what you said no the market caps 2sat
one good okay so so 130 billion dollars
the I mean it's hard to grow that with
from with a toll collecting business
model right so so do you see all of this
as grow the PI of the industrial
business because we just have smarter
more powerful technology than anybody
else if people want to buy more of our
things or do you actually see a world
where the software part of the business
grows the PI measurably and that is a
big chunk of you know whether it's the
toll and the usage of the software where
it's just selling the software itself so
if you consider GE almost 60% of our of
our businesses service based anyway so
in some ways we're reinventing the
service model I think an installed base
of technology doesn't go away the value
of it may change over time you're trying
to prevent it from being commoditized
but you can't run an airline without jet
engines
you can't run a railroad without
locomotives so I think we're still in
those big iron businesses where few
competitors huge technical advantage so
it's not easy necessary to come into
those markets but it's not as it's not
enough and so the service model is
really what's changing and so you will
continue to have contractual service
agreements which we've had but now you
will layer on those additional sort of
subscription models
thing as a service it's really becomes
GE as a service to help you run your
business better what do you want let's
go after ok good ok thank you well
because I'm really said about data right
now so I'm so so you said data and you
said toll collecting what do you see as
this energy then between the different
businesses is there a requirement that
everything needs to go into one major
you know data platform and we leverage
it across all the businesses is there a
sort of unifying principle about how
you're going to use data for the the
business going for I think our unifying
principle is assets under management so
that's a new metric for us how many
assets can you get GES or others that
are connected to your cloud your
predicts industrial clouds so again if
we're investing in industrial scale data
and analytics all that goes with it the
correlations between one jet engine I
think the I think I have my math right
the one jet engine flight is like a
terabyte of data imagine you're running
a whole airline imagine if someone like
us and we're servicing 200 Airlines so
we're talking huge amounts of data and
so I I think you have to you know that
that's some of what you have to think
through in those models are you
publishing your assets under management
numbers yet not yet but we will but but
we have every business has a target for
what they think their assets under
management G's or others again if other
people are building apps on our platform
those are assets that we can have is you
know we're not the data is private but
the ability to take the insights from
the data and if you're flying a jet
engine over the the sort of rough harsh
terrain of the Middle East versus flying
it over you know North America
you have different wear and tear and the
more the more kind of use cases and
scenarios you can get in there the
better you can predict the rate of
failure or the rate of how hot it is so
the more data you have the better you
can predict what's going to happen and
that's really what we're offering is
that sort of predictability that that
maintenance that ability to run your
company better if we were sitting here
in four years and it didn't go as you
would hope than planned
what would be your best guess as to why
what would have gotten in the way what
keeps you up at night well I think it
can we go fast enough
and our customers ready I you know in
some ways I think for us it's like let's
get things connected and then let's all
figure it out so the revenue will follow
we're already at fifteen billion dollars
of software sales so so that feels good
and starting from just a couple billion
so that feels pretty good to us that
we're we're moving in the right way
we're look we have productivity targets
I think we're looking to get five
billion dollars worth of productivity so
how do you get your teams to go faster
well you incent them to go faster saying
and sending them on velocity and speed
how fast can you get these assets under
management how many new revenue sources
and streams of revenue can you you know
a paying customer is a lot more valuable
than a development customer two
customers are more valuable than just
one customer so I think there are those
kind of sort of what you'd imagine in a
seed growing company state early stage
two big kind of metrics well obviously
ge is one of the things that's most well
known for is its leadership tracks and
leadership development and growing you
know leaders and and all of that and has
this idea of digital sort of started to
come through in your leadership
development tracks how do you grow the
next era of leaders to think like you
are thinking and have driven because you
have this unique experience on the media
side seeing that disruption so it's sort
of core to - you know what you've had to
deal with how do you ensure that other
leaders are learning like what's going
to be happening in their business or
their you know particularly it's a good
question I mean a couple things happen
to us at as as digital was taking off we
had GE Capital Faison and really the
company face into one of our biggest
crisis crises in history with the
financial downturn and we've this last
year announced were shedding GE Capital
and helped us focus but what we also
realized is there was a lot of
bureaucracy that had crept into the
company financial services health care I
mean just so we were we were naturally
slow because of the fear that sort of
came out of the downturn the the less
ability to feel good about managing risk
that comes along the same time digital
that just doesn't work so we've had to
just lead a whole cultural revolution we
call it fast works it's really lean
startup plus a lot of other things
we've brought into the culture more of a
VC like approach to funding and moving
fast and so we've just we've just
announced a revamping our whole
leadership development program and
digital is at the core of everything
every way we're developing our next
leaders in the company what do you think
you have to train those leaders on then
like what is the what is the new skill
it sure it's the responsiveness agility
the decentralized luckily we globalized
in the early part of this decade I'd say
you know around 2000 really last decade
and this week we've spent a huge effort
to go where the growth was globally that
helped us be understand how to operate
in a decentralized world probably we
were ready for digital and that kind of
that kind of arena but I think your page
here is really really helpful of what
we're trying to get the leadership team
good German yeah yeah thank you I'm
taking that page back I sense it too
yeah
and do you see it as I mean clearly it's
not sort of binary like it's not one or
the other have you fused them together
in ways that are is your own unique
model like how do you I mean cuz you're
not getting rid of Six Sigma are you no
okay
so and and there's then the
responsiveness and that you know agile
on the other side is the same person
gonna have to learn how to do both
that's gonna be two DNA's in the
organization well and Rob knows this
from the days of Six Sigma and GE I mean
this was the Jack Welch hallmark at GE
and it was very powerful it was all
about quality and it helps you scale
faster there's a lot of great things
about Six Sigma but trust me when I was
at NBC we did not need to know how to do
Six Sigma and there are parts of the
company that didn't need to but it was
forced down and there's a little bit of
risk aversion that comes with that and
you want your jet engine to not be I
don't you want to be 50 Sigma if that's
even possible so that's part of what's
happening now is you have to use the
tool for the application but you can't
expect everybody to do everything the
exact same way so yes you still need the
efficiency in the Six Sigma operated
scale but not everybody needs to do it
and so some of the lean methodology
helps you iterate with your customer get
a product out faster understand but then
when it's ready to scale you better know
how to use Six Sigma to get it out the
way it needs to be and how has I mean
you guys are in let's like far enough in
where you must have seen parts of the
organization that just can't adapt like
they're just not gonna be able to make
it to the other side on on this fusion
of digital and industrial how do you
deal with that is that like a full and
immersive retraining is that a okay
we're gonna have to actually sideline
that organization how are you dealing
with the fact of the you you know
hundreds of thousand people that have to
move along with this journey so I'll
give you I I spent a lot of time on the
commercial sides let me give you an
example of just even the funnel the the
pyramid that we're looking at in terms
of the sale at the base you still have
product sales I mean you still have to
go and talk to the technical leader at
the railroad and say here are here's all
the great specs of our engine the middle
is really your value cell it's really a
much more a much more much more focused
on some of those outcomes I talked about
and the top is really just a very
consultative let me sit next to the CFO
help you run this railroad better and
we've had - so most of our base was at
that product level
and we've had to bring in sort of the
value sellers and also those
consultative some people make the
transition many don't
and so you either keep the people who
are really good at the product and you
bring in new people you move the other
people up and and that's happening in
every function in the company some
people self-select out some people make
the transition so you have to offer
training and development but you also
have to be very honest with people who
don't feel comfortable this is the way
the world is going and maybe there's
something else somewhere else that you
want to want to do it and they go to
Honeywell or something you guys have
last question would be then you have I
think at this point you know sort of
fully immerse yourselves in Silicon
Valley you're doing venture capital
you're doing significant partnerships
both internally on the internal IT side
as well as externally on customer facing
stuff what is the is there an overall
framework on the what you decide to
build by invest partner in and and do
you see the things like the venture
capital side is that a is that stuff
that you ultimately want to acquire you
just want to stay close to you want to
you know just support from an ecosystem
standpoint how do you think about all of
the start-up relationships that you guys
are doing I think it's all the above I
mean I I'd say you guys probably learned
at the classic business school three box
core adjacent new real is really still
guides us and helpful here and so we
tend to use our venture capability for
the new because that's really hard to do
always in the core and then there's some
interesting hybrids on the on the
adjacent so I think that's still a very
good framework we want a partner for
speed and sharing risk and reward you
want to invest in a start-up because
they give you a window there they're
able to move faster in certain cases
maybe we want to acquire them maybe we
just want to have a stake in it we have
this saying do you want to be a hundred
percent of nothing or twenty percent of
something that's going to work and so
again it's a way to protect the way I
like to think about it and it's sort of
what we call position capital so it's
it's a speed and it's also a way to
think about capital allocation and
you're positioning yourself for when the
change shows up and you're ready for it
I can you know we're doing it with our
lighting business right now or we're
actually trans transforming our LED
business into an energy business and it
involves solar and storage and on-site
power generation that hasn't scaled yet
but it's going to and we need to be
there and ready to take take it but in
the history of corporate venture capital
its especially companies coming into the
valley coming up you know stands on
redwood Sand Hill Road
there's a lot of sort of dead bodies of
that process how are you guys doing
something uniquely different you have a
different perspective than other
corporate venture capital group's well I
think it's not I mean sure there's a
part of the portfolio that's a return on
investment yes we want some of these
investments to pay off we want the fund
to be self-sustaining
but there's a whole strategic imperative
of can we partner I'll give you a good
example right now in the railroad
business unmanned aerial vehicles drones
are very important they're important in
the power business to survey power lines
so we've invested in a number of drone
companies software companies because
they're going to help together we're
gonna get there faster and so that that
helps like are we gonna go buy our where
no but the fact that we can put their
software platform together with our
navigation platform means we can both
get there fast I sort of shake up over
time but does that sort of shake up the
organization a bit which says we've got
this air wave thing if you can't do that
or learn from them yeah does that do
culturally well culturally it comes back
to that question of people using oh wait
a minute but I was going to do that
maybe but you can't you don't you know I
we had a we had a little internal
contest recently where we asked people
to pitch out ideas we're gonna fund them
for a year sort of seed stage funding
number and one of them was is a drone
software navigation it's awesome but
it's like number 10 on their top seven
things that they are focused on but tens
gonna happen so how do we use ventures
to create the momentum so that when 10
rises up in three to five years we're
ready to scale it you need to keep it at
just the right level and I've learned a
lot about timing and you can be too
early and we all know companies are
usually accused of being too late but
you can also be too early right awesome
combs like thank you so much thank you